seems Shakira has a message for ex
Gerard PK's girlfriend Clara chiamardi
and that she's come out stronger since
her split from the Soccer Star
[Music]
in a new interview with Mexican TV
network in Moss the singer opens up
about women supporting each other
clearly stating quote there's a special
place in hell for women who don't
support other women now Shakira doesn't
name names but seems It's aimed at Clara
Gerard's new lady love it's been quite a
journey Shakira's new start began last
summer when she split from the former
Soccer Pro after 12 years together not
too long after their breakup Gerard was
spotted with Clara I guess that it
happens to all of us once in a while you
know
us women
that you think that you're in a real
relationship and it's not as real as it
seems
but despite the life change Shakira says
she's quote enough for myself today I've
always been emotionally dependent on men
I have to confess I've been in love with
love because of that history I've been
able to see things from a different
perspective and I know now I'm enough
that relationship with oneself
in which so many so many things come to
play you know especially being committed
to your own goals in life and not giving
up and not abandoning or throwing in the
towel too soon just because the
environment tries to bring you down yeah
and Shakira hasn't been afraid to
express her feelings on social media
[Music]
yeah
to celebrate Valentine's Day she
seemingly poked fun at her ongoing drama
with Gerard lip syncing to sizz's song
Kill Bill
[Music]
the best idea his new girlfriend's next
time
[Music]
sometimes the message definitely you
have to walk through whatever's
happening and it seems that's what
Shakira is doing now putting focus on
her two kids whom she shares with Gerard
in the interview Shakira explains when a
woman has to face the attacks of life
she comes out stronger there are dreams
that are broken and you have to pick up
the little pieces from the ground and
put yourself together again and also be
an example to my children
[Music]
thank you